welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal Britain's Queen Elizabeth is
presiding today over an unprecedented
meeting of royal family members amid the
turmoil over Prince Harry and Meghan's
decision to step back from their royal
duties so at the meeting Harry his
brother William and his father Prince
Charles they'll all be at the Queen's
home in eastern England to work out a
solution everybody hopes Charlie d'Agata
is just outside the estate with more on
the story
Charlie this is shaping up to be quite
the meeting yes it is it's the summit
the crisis summit and welcome to Sandra
now this is one of the Queen's favorite
country estates where she comes really
to get away from it all but today it is
the scene of that summit which could
have impact on the royal family for
generations to come
it's going down the monarch Her Majesty
the Queen the heir to the throne Prince
Charles the future King Prince William
and a renegade Prince Harry no friendly
family gathering but an unprecedented
crisis meeting called after Harry and
Megan said they wanted to pull out of
their royal duties and spend more time
in North America in a shot public
announcement that reportedly broadsided
the Queen were told Megan who's
currently in Canada with son Archie may
take part by phone on the agenda the
couple's role going forward whose to pay
for their transatlantic lifestyle their
security detail until now paid for by
British taxpayers how they'll be able to
keep their home Frogmore cottage and
what commercial deals they'll be able to
strike the crisis has sparked frenzied
speculation in the media from a backlash
aimed at Megan - reports she and Harry
felt bullied by Prince William a claim
the brothers denied this morning however
there has been tension between them felt
by Prince William says royal
correspondent Roy Anika he feels very
sad that there's been this split that
seemed that going to what he described
as separate entities you know he talked
about not being able to put his arm
around his brother anymore and that
makes him sad dealing with those
divisions is something Harry has touched
on in the past where brothers will
always be brothers and we're certainly
on different paths at the moment but I
will always be there for him and as I
know he'll always be there for me
critics argue that Megan knew what she
was signing up for when she said yes
still William may try to salvage a way
to keep the couple in the fold
he's hoping I think that they can come a
point to where how he Megan feel you
know happy enough in their own
progressive new roles I don't you know
he's keen that the royal family supports
them now for the time being Harry is
still carrying out his royal duties
including welcoming wheelchair
participants of the 2021 Rugby World Cup
later this week go let's hope they work
it all out Charlie so it's a win-win for
everybody involved can you imagine how
tense everybody must be feeling on all
sides surprised that we actually know
about this summit and it's been
publicized and everybody's aware because
people are leaking a lot of details
that's why thank you very much Charlie
d'Agata
you